foreign
[Music]
things YouTube channel and welcome to
the sit down where I interview fathers
about their experience in the court
system here in the UK um today I have a
special guest I'm Graham welcome to the
show hi
um so tell me you've worked with
parental alienation UK and fathers for
justice that's correct yeah what made
you start working with those groups
so is when
it was the start of my my separation
always with me now my ex-wife
um
came home one day
the wife had left note on the table
didn't know where my son lived for two
years
um
over the first probably months trying to
get any form of communication with my
ex-wife was
was pretty desperate pretty awkward
pretty toxic so one did you see this
coming or was it just out you had no
clue
so it wasn't like a rocky patch it
wasn't we've got yeah we're going
through a tough time there was there was
issues with her mother and father and
um they're not particularly nice people
okay okay and because I didn't jump when
they wanted me to jump fit into the
status quo they wanted me to fit into
um what do you mean the status quo so
for them it was I had very much get into
line I wasn't allowed to so I was an IC
consultant uh an I.T consultant I was a
self-employed going into big businesses
and things like this that's a good job
though no they didn't but they didn't
think so no I was because I had no
education behind me because I went from
the start on my own okay and
um grinded it out if you like from
Grassroots who was I to do that when I'm
not educated of course all of a sudden I
financially leprog most of them so they
were they were more educated like they
were like an educated family and they
just looked down upon you because you
were not absolutely properly even though
School nowadays makes you dumber in my
opinion but the weird thing is her
father wasn't educated wasn't educated
himself but pretended he was some middle
class
gentlemen when you know it was a whole
different world so you came home one day
and she was gone all her stuff was gone
all the stuff so she took some stuff uh
just a note on the table but over the
next six weeks she would suddenly start
she was still coming to the house and
would just be taking little bits and
moving bits around the house and what
what did the notes say note said
um I
I need some space I need some time to uh
decide what I want to do ironically two
weeks before which probably should give
an indication she was trying to say
let's have a trial breakup and I was
going you know I'm not stupid you know
if you want to do that that's fine but I
should still think that I should still
see our son you know and obviously I'm
working full-time in the moment so while
you're working part-time
let me see him every weekend
and then we'll kind of work out from
there and that's really where the
problem came
because I refuse to only see him once a
fortnight and one evening in the week
bear mine was only two at the time so
the amount of time in the evening would
have been good for him it's quite slim
um and she didn't want you to see her
son at all actually first of all only
wanted me to see him within the time she
wants me to see him which was once a
fortnight once or where once a fortnight
once every two weeks oh once so in UK we
call the Fortnight Fortnight is two
weeks okay
um and even the week
every week but for me I want to be a
committed father I want to be in my
son's life as much as I can
um and that was only frowned upon
because I wanted to be in my son's life
when she then left
um
she said she went to friends for the for
the weekend
didn't know where my son was I said okay
well can't at least see him this weekend
do you have your time but at least let
me just see my son this weekend
give yourself time
she refused that
um
and then Along Came Monday I've decided
not to come back clearly that was always
going to happen it was all about trauma
because she knew I had a cousin coming
over for the weekend
and I was gonna obviously me and my
cousin and his kids were gonna have a
day out so she knew it would wreck that
weekend so it'd be a weekend of the most
toughest for me emotionally and
humiliation
um and as I'm not starting to come back
um I will
um we'll discuss
how are our you know arrangements to see
my son
um a couple so I left it I was just
changing jobs as well at the time
um sorry not straight away so I was
still a nice hotel and self-employed at
the time
uh the next couple of weeks I was trying
to have some form of communication with
her and it was just very blunt and then
had an email a text message from her out
the blue saying would you like to see
you'll see my son I said yes I really
would I uh can we just speak over the
phone rather than text message is this
just easier and when complete radio
silence
and next thing I know if you ever want
to see your son again we'd have to go to
court
now there was also prior to that time
there was a four week four to five week
time span which were going I'll apply
for court so don't do it don't worry
about it I'll let you know so she kept
telling you she was going to apply for a
quote I never did and by how much how
much time it passed it was four weeks
total from like she left to saying in
order to see your son half
months
five and a half months
so you knew he didn't see your son at
all I'm not communication didn't know
where he was
I officially didn't know where we lived
for two years
oh so and at two years old that's like a
different kid in six months so when he
wore yeah exactly so when
I saw him on my first day's contact with
court when did when I did go to court
Effigy father Justice really helped me
my economy was amazing
um I had every other week I had every
other weekend
full weekend and the week in the middle
I had them for Adam for half a day as
well and that was after the after bit so
I just want to make sure I understand so
she leaves six months later she says you
have to go to court one so she left over
the next four to let's say four to eight
weeks you know at the times I'm sorry if
it's
um so over that time it was I'm applying
for court applying for court and then
suddenly oh no it's not me hospital
Court as for you
um and that was at about six months that
was about five and a half years yeah
well yeah between four and eight I think
four and ten weeks eight weeks okay okay
uh with there's no communication with my
son not knowing where they were
um
uh not knowing what was happening I
didn't be told that she wants me to
apply for it
um that was the point around I then
engaged with f4j
um because I thought because there was
lots of communication back and forth
where I was being all of a sudden being
accused of everything left right and
Center that I was a domestic abuser I
was financially abusive I was
emotionally abusive because I had one
argument in seven years
um wow so this wasn't even like a toxic
relationship this wasn't no no you had
one argument in seven years and that was
two weeks before she left and I have a
feeling and I believe that was because
she was on her way out the door
one argument seven years
like a shouting argument you might have
disagreements right but a shouting
arguments one in seven years wow
okay so uh four to eight weeks she says
roughly
you have to take me to court and it
wasn't until six months that you got to
court uh yes okay and then what happened
um so the court and by then just just to
make sure I got it right by then she had
already accused you of abuse okay
yeah so now you're going to court with
this thing saying I'm I've abused her
all the applications to court okay
um and I'm assuming she was working with
a women's shelter women's Aid women's
Aid so in the end she actually applied
for court in the end anyway so with the
help of f4j
they positioned it
they know the they know the system So
eventually she actually had to apply for
it anyway
um
at that time I'd also applied for it I'd
had a few pressures myself of people
telling me I should apply for it anyway
so it turned out we had two applications
but in the in in the long run it
actually turned out that was actually a
good thing because it showed that we
both wanted
because by her applying to court she's
saying I want him to see my son
oh you know our son I'm playing caught
saying I want to see my son
um so you can't really go to court at
that point and go
I don't want him to see a child so it
kind of worked in my favor I think on
that one anyway
um
the judge came straight in
um and said there's Mr Howard have
um parental responsibility of our son I
said yes
but she suggests you do have fun for the
nation oh sorry friend responsibility of
your son I said yes I definitely do we
were married at the time
um I am his father I'm on the birth
certificate
um and then he said well
there's no reason for him not to steal a
child there's nothing imported anything
she's put in the application doesn't
mean anything it's not for this cause
so effectively all the information that
gets put in the court is to try and hit
a a spectrum
of D.A it's like a it's like um
a point system okay okay so if you
imagine it's like pillars yeah part of
domestic abuse you've got Financial
abuse you've got emotional abuse you've
got coercive Behavior Financial control
so there's Financial abuse Financial
control you've got a coercive control
you've got emotional abuse you've got
all sorts okay so imagine they're all
the pillars okay and then you've got a
point system
where it all starts at one okay okay so
these are the colors that's it now when
women's Aid
um makes this
yes yes and then the ten like one to ten
maybe down the side that's it okay so
tan one is the bottom that's it yeah so
10 being the highest number yeah on the
system of severity now being a spectrum
like any other spectrums we know of
everybody's always on the spectrum
because it won't be a spectrum that's
how you measure right
when they sold it to the government they
sold to the government that only if they
hit you hit a certain number so let's
say five yeah five five so maybe six
okay and that's an abusive relationship
within that pillar okay okay with it
yeah
um
now that's how they sold it to the
government it has to equal five when it
got when it was suddenly put into put
into government they then used the car
salesman tactic of suddenly stacking it
so if I've got one here one there one
here one there that equals six so if you
so basically means every every person's
relationship is known as domestically
abusive because we're all somewhere did
I do the account yes I managed the joint
accounts to make sure food was on the
table uh but I was told I was
financially abusive and then cool and so
she could say maybe he yelled at me the
one time
so then they put a two on this pillar
and then they put a one on like maybe
you told her you can't go to a club and
then that's another one okay okay and
you so it's like car you know like when
you go and buy buy a car you get your
Finance deals your loans and you start
off with the basic package and they go
oh do you want this extra package and
it's only extra 12 pounds a month I'm
waiting for six pounds a month and
before you know you've spent another 100
pounds or 100 more than you wanted to
spend it's called stacking it's
basically so you don't see what's going
on
so they use that mentality that
technique of stacking it and who is they
that's women's Aid so women's Aid and
women's Aid brings this to the quote so
women's day put that to government
certainly the court have to go off that
Spectrum
okay so women's Aid pitched this to the
government and the government bought it
but when initially it was more about
they would only have to get a five at
one but then those sneaky way they went
around it was letting them stack yep
okay and then basically anyone could say
they're in a domestically abusive
basically anybody if you look at it if
everybody had one argument if you one of
you could usually we take roles in a
relationship so I'm not best to cook so
she might do the cooking for example
that would be I was told I made her to
cook I made her cook let miles in her
under my control emotional control
um I manage the accounts to make sure
food was on the table I'm now Financial
controlling I had money in a savings
account my own personal savings account
that was financially abusive because she
should have been a joint account where
she could freely agree to get it
okay so you go to court and she starts
putting these against you yes okay and
so what happens so
be fatally Judge first thing off he said
I've never done this before but I'm
gonna go right down the middle on
everything so you can get it you can get
one's Fortnight you're gonna get a day
uh on the previous weeks he's seeing
Ernie every single week so that's my
son's name
um uh
we I was trying to get a
um
video call them once a week as well we
on the week that I didn't see him in the
week so
um I wasn't fortunately successful in
doing that
um
but I was also on target to get
50 50
responsibility custody yeah literally On
Target to get it and then unfortunately
I then lost it
because of ex-wife there's a few so she
broke the court order five times so it
was a three he was in what's called an
in what's called an intermediary
order
because usually there's two sets of you
get directions hearing
and then you get the final hearing
and within that period of time they give
you an intermediary
um uh order so it's an opportunity to
show to the court
that you're a good parent
die every eye across every t
um
uh and she broke the order five times or
if she won't let you see the kid so her
son she'd made it very so she actually
this is where it gets more
complex and toxic she actually turned my
family against me
okay so she used my mother to break the
court order
and how so
um
my mother would
um suddenly have an issue with picking
him up because he was because I when I
was in court let's go back to days when
I'm cool I'll do a part of them jumping
around a little bit
um there's a there's a company called
kafkas okay and they're supposed to be
the court advisory or responsible
responsibility if you like over the
child and do what's the best interests
for that child
um they're nowhere near
caf
Cas okay okay now they're supposed to
meet with both parents so imagine my
first hearing
they
um
spent 45 minutes with my ex-wife
and less than 10 minutes for me
of which I was told that because the
police win that time I forgot to say
the police arranged for me to see them
for 24 my son for 24 hours
and when I went to give him back her
parents ripped burning out of my arms
and he was then crying down the car park
um
and um
I was she told me it was my fault and I
shouldn't have shown emotion
and she was putting that against me
because you were you were crying
oh you were crying because they ripped
my son was calling up me didn't want to
leave me so she went down his mother her
mother went down to my arms grabbed him
and ran away and how so I still how did
your mom so your mom had an issue
picking them up from so in Kafka so at
the court
I said to kafkas I am primary Handover
if there's an issue my mother's
secondary Handover
um
but when she went to court when she went
into the court hearing she said that I
agreed to her being my mother being
primary
I said also you know it was oh yeah uh
yeah he's agreed for his mother to be
primary and him to be secondary
and then said oh there's something else
I forgot we're going to put a community
communicate a communication book in
place as well
so the only communication I had with his
mother was via a book
buy a book what do you mean a book so
like a little writing book so I'd write
like messages date and time dates and
that was it to your mother to her son's
mother yeah and my mother would then
pick him up at a supermarket car park
um a Tesco's supermarket market car park
um at a sad time on each day
um
my mother tried almost broke the order
within 24 hours
how by saying to me I need to change the
date time this and that and the other
after getting the call order I'm just
going no you need to do well it says in
the court order why you can't do without
me can you
well you know I can't I'll best be nice
to me then
um
I also found out that prior to
that six months period that I wasn't
seeing my son my mother was still seeing
my son and my sister was seeing my son
and I wasn't and never told me why would
they do that
you don't know unfortunately that's the
way my mother is
um because I just can't imagine like
that's the like why would they pick her
over her side over you so she was very
good at being
girly girly
your ex-wife was yeah and
um
very good at being girly girly very good
at
just getting them on board and they in
the end at one point they seem to have
loved her more than they love me
um
that's part of the other toxic family I
think as well
um
unfortunately so my parents were divorce
themselves as well so
so that she manipulated your mom and
your sister and maybe my father and your
father and my cousins
and your cousins
wow I had no one
so they all turned on you and didn't
want you to see their your son they
every time I asked them that I need you
to support me here I stopped
communication with the ex because
obviously that plays into her Court they
all said no we're going to continue
contacting her because then she what she
was doing she was carrying on
communication with my family and she
said this what's she saying this for I
don't know
um so what would she tell your family
would she say that you abused her yes I
was abusive and all the same thing I was
financially abusive
um oh so she's basically started
brainwashing your family that's the best
way to explain it yes you get into
thinking that and like because she's a
woman basically she she was like kind of
crying wolf in a way exactly and
um your mother your sister your father
and your cousins okay and
um and then basically she would use them
to get you to break the order
yeah so like she would make it so you
didn't see your son
through your family because she made
your mother the primary
like care like person so your mom had to
pick up your son and she was speaking to
your mom and making it so and then she
could go to court and say you broke the
order correct it was it was my mother
who broke the order
if you imagine if that now happens that
shows a dysfunctional family
oh okay and that's the route she was
going there so then you go to the second
court date and what happens
um uh
she then said to me so um
the first few
days I had on my son weekends one
weekend I asked for can you bring in
some toys with him because I hadn't seen
him for
five months I didn't know it was toy
tastes had changed you know
I asked for clothes I asked for Wellies
boots and asked him for a jacket she put
that against me in the courtroom said to
me that was demanding Behavior
wow that's the worst she could put
against me at that point
demanding Behavior demanding Behavior
okay and I had to discuss to the court
so out of those three obviously the
court Judiciary System has to go has to
choose a topic
I had to explain to the court why I
asked for toys to accompany my son
um which was I just want to support him
I didn't know the tools I had were now
too young for him
um I wanted to be able to know roughly
what his days were make it comfortable
for him and then I'd be able to go to
Toys R Us yes afterwards yeah
um in fact I didn't even know what his
nappy size was I didn't know what his
clothes size was when I picked him up he
was just literally in his clothes in his
jacket and a toy in his hand and that
was it
he was two and a half then
uh yes he would have been two and a half
years
okay so then what did the court what did
the court tell you so the court asked me
to explain why I asked for toys so I
went into why I explain it while I asked
for toys
um
uh
and then they said
um
due to the breakages in the course order
um particular disagreements going on
um they only gave me then once a
fortnight and that was it now why so
once every other week they give you I
also had to go in the advice was to go
in to ask for that as well because
otherwise I could get nothing
because of sight because leading up to
the so it was a Christmas period
um I was supposed to see him Christmas
Day
it all broke down the night before
um and then my mother started to try and
reduce the amount of contact I was
getting
um she canceled or contact
which obviously played into my ex's
hands and I'd see my son for another two
and a half months
so you saw once at two and when he's two
and a half years old and then you didn't
see him I saw him for about eight to
nine weeks
and then because it was like four months
yeah okay
for four and a half month period for the
next court hearing
um and then uh I didn't see him for
about two months yeah I thought yeah
about about two two and a half months
um
and then they ordered you that you can
only see them every other week yeah and
because of the she was then trying to
stop me I wasn't allowed to pick Ernie
up to hand to do Handover because your
mother was the primary and also because
she was scared
wow that I might cause an argument in a
in a in in the entrance of a supermarket
when my primary objective was just go
collect myself say hello and go you know
so I had so I had to put myself into a
child contact center to do purely
Handover
um which obviously then that goes
against me anyway but either I see my
son or I don't so I had to accept that
um uh so yes we did so I was there I was
doing hand over
I was there 20 minutes before 20 minutes
after
um and then I was out the door again I
did that for two years
it's two years once every other week you
would see yourself so you would see him
twice a month yes
for two years and then what would happen
next because you said this whole thing
took five years I think you said the
divorce yeah the divorce itself
um or it's been how long has everything
been total till now
five years so today yeah to today
uh
probably talking five and a half six
years now okay so I'll do six to round
it so six years the first two and a half
years you had the six month period of
not seeing him and then two years of
seeing him once every other week yeah
okay so then what happened
um dead on the two years
she found out that I'd had to sell my
car
I was also had a girlfriend at the time
and she got in contact with the
ex-girlfriend with my girlfriend's
family and just started to cause a lot
of trouble between me and Nick
eventually after a year we had to break
up it got too bad she was giving
um
making the same
allegations even though I explained it
to my to my girlfriend at the time what
had happened
um gave her every piece of document even
showed how the contradictions were
between what she was saying and what
actually happened
um but I had to end the relationship
because in the end even her own her
girlfriend's family were starting to
believe your ex
how did she get in contact with them so
it turned out
my
wow there's two routes I think so my
mother knew
one of my girlfriend's friends mothers I
think that my mother then made contact
that way
um and my mother said to me
um then started to make up even more
allegations and then sent me an email
saying well if you don't call me I'll
have to keep saying it
basically trying to coerce me and speak
to make it as horrible as possible
um
so and then also then making her sister
would actually make direct contact with
my ex-wife as well
find my mother
um
and then I was being told and then every
every couple of days it would be I've
just been told this I said we've already
gone through this we've gone through
this eventually I thought that's cool
because it's probably too much to have
to defend yourself every single day
every single day you'd have to finish
off something yeah it is and what do you
attribute like what do you attribute
everyone be believe in her too like was
it is she a narcissist a crazy good liar
what do you think it's just the way that
the World Views women like what do you I
think it's a I think it's a mixture
because to me like this is so like I
think you automatic stuff like that's it
you're okay I just I think of my brother
in this situation and I just like I
don't know if someone told me that he
did something like I would have I just
wouldn't really believe it so like what
what do you think like why did all these
people take her seriously
I think that in
I don't know too much about the us but
in the UK with obviously the media and
that sort of thing if
a woman says I've been domestically
abused
no automatically everybody believes it
well why is she saying it
because there was someone in the 80s
um primary school of the time was
Margaret Thatcher and women's Aid said
that a mother would not
say anything bad about the father unless
it was necessary unless it was true
hence why the mother should always the
children's story with a mother of course
I've imagined that now gets manipulated
so you think it was brainwashing
basically by the media oh social social
yeah okay so um it doesn't help you know
I think there's other factors but yeah
after the two years like it was
um did she try to restrict your contact
further yeah
um so after I sold my car
um
because I needed to pay bills because at
this point I've been defrauded at work
and
um still trying to deal with those cases
that work at work I was being told that
because I was quite open with what had
happened
um we also worked in a in a fairly
female environment that meant I could be
at risk to them
oh so because you worked in it I'm
surprised I.T is a female environment
but it is it is um well it's both it's
it it you know it's
um but but it was female enough and so
when they caught when that you were
getting domestic abuse allegations they
needed you out because you were too much
of a liability
that I don't know I believe is a
potential with that I do believe I was
then also
um
uh
an easy target to say you really need
this job don't you knowing I was then I
was in need of a job at the time because
I needed it for the call
um so overnight they took 30 for my
salary which was about 39 000 a year
they they took it like a pay cut
oh wow I'm creating a policy just for me
so a fraudulent policy to make it look
legitimate
and were you on child support at this
time
was I paying child support yeah yes how
much were you paying a month
right
so at this point I was paying 250 pounds
a month okay so let's say
um for the US people that's like three
roughly like 3 40 or 3 30.
more 400 I'd probably say
what do you think okay 400. it's
normally it's not it's about double not
quite it's just not quite double but
under double isn't it
um
now here's the thing as well is that
after my second court hearing in 2018
she also defraud me to the child
maintenance service which that charmain
service is child support
okay and they were cut they're an
organization that's a government-run
organization
um who who calculate
child support now you don't have to go
down that route
or you can so my ex just did everything
possible to go down every possible
formal route and make things as
difficult as possible
um she made out our two jobs at forty
thousand pounds a year
um which was not true and for six months
because of that I had to pay 1500 pounds
a month in child maintenance
oh wow
1500 pounds a month and also at that
time as well
our mortgage was coming out of its fixed
rate
so that went up by 200 pound a month
okay and she refused to because clearly
I said but clearly this divorce isn't
going to go over overnight
so I was still I was still paying the
whole mortgage and were you living in
the house okay so we need to because our
both our names on the mortgage I was
paying the mortgage right
we need to sign into something to save
me some money here
um and she refused that for another six
months as well around the same time so I
was paying 200 a month extra on my
mortgage plus 1500 pound child month
child maintenance uh how long because
six months I paid that six months wow so
I paid effectively three months worth or
three years worth of child maintenance
in six months
and she also put me five thousand pounds
in debt retrospectively
okay
um and it took me six months to evidence
that to which our main service every
time I said right here's the evidence to
prove I don't have two jobs a couple
days later she'd call back
and then deny it and say something else
and then they recalculate all over again
and every time did you get paid back for
the five grand or no so luckily I had
that one written off okay
um but they refused to pay me back what
so that five thousand pounds was on top
of right what the new payments were
going to be okay
so that got re after another year that
got written off the 5 000 pounds did but
you did you ever get paid back for the
1500 a month no because they said
because I paid it although it was
evidentially
why don't you go to jail if you don't
pay it they told me if I don't pay it
they'll take my passport away and I'd go
to prison
wow and so they essentially just stole
they even said to me if we want to and
this is John maintenance service he said
if we want to we can take 40 of your
salary if we want to I said but you're
taking 90 of it
well not on this information I said but
I've already proven to you time and time
again
um
so yeah and this is all during the three
this throughout three and a half years
because that this is around the time you
and your girlfriend are together yes
that's happened during that time as well
okay yeah so this is drawn to the whole
of 2018. okay rightly to the beginning
of 2019. okay and so what did that lead
to
um eventually
they agreed with me it's our main
service
um then she started to tell people that
isolated five thousand pounds family
friends I found out uh friends she
um
uh recruited well the term is recruited
um a couple of friends wives
who then were then causing toxic toward
me and then we also get information on
me and passing on to Lucy my ex
so she could then use it in the
courtroom
um
I also had a friend who I thought she
was a friend
and she was passing information on to
Lucy as well
um uh what was I doing financially
what what potential I'll be doing in
court
um anything anything to put against me
in the divorce
when did you go home you said you were
homeless at one point so back in 2021 I
lost my home so as the house got sold I
had nowhere to go I was back by this
point I was declared bankrupt on the 5th
of October 2020 because I physically I'd
spent 30 Grand in the courts so you
spent including these daily costs
obviously there's like how much how much
did everything cost you would you say
roughly about 30 000 pounds 33 was that
include the 1500 pounds a month in child
support
and the no you said the five grand got
written off and the
and the other child it probably was
including that I can't remember because
I did I did I had to do a summary in my
in my divorce and there was there was a
figure I can't remember that was part of
the figure or not and you might have
been what I paid actually yeah 30 000
pounds and were at this point you were
making 40 000 pounds a year but at this
point because I've been defrauded my
salary got taken down from 38 000 a year
to 25. oh so you were only making 25
000 pounds a year
and now you had 30 000 pounds of bills
basically I used all my life savings wow
and that'll start to go into debt and
how old were you oh so I'm 39 now and I
was 34 35 at the time okay 34.
okay
um and how long did you see him every
other week till still now okay so that
that stayed at least till now yeah I do
have so I'm no longer doing a contact
sensor I hand over I pick them up from
school now and then she collects them
from my place on a Sunday
um
uh
uh there was a time when at the point of
the two-year marker where she knew I
sold my car
um she suddenly said right we're going
to change everything
you're going to come collect him 30
miles away
but give me this great offer to make it
look make it look like such an amazing
deal tell you what we do you pick him up
on a Friday at two o'clock in the
afternoon jump off at nursery on a
Monday morning have all your weekend
this and that and the other to make it
look like the best deal possible but she
knew that you didn't know it was
impossible if I did it by train to get
to it because it was this place called
busage which is a place called Stroud
and it's like a little village that's
not on the main height you know nearby a
round trip would have would have taken
me four hours so that's two hours for me
and then two hours for my son on the way
back and vice versa on Sunday and the
time
um
so I eventually said well I can't do the
Monday because he won't get to nursery
on time but no one's in the nursery by
half past eight in the morning
which is gonna be impossible
so it was a Sunday and if I took him
back on the Sunday
I'd have no way of getting back
because all the buses would be stopping
all the trains would be stopping there
would it be nothing nothing to go
um so it looked online what a great deal
but she knew it was just it was just
emotional
did any of your friends and family start
to see what she was doing
after a while yes
it took a while
um
because it's always well why is she
saying this then I don't know I found
myself having to be
Fielding a lot of stuff and having to be
a mind reader on things
um it wasn't too
probably
beginning of 2020
that they started to re-see what was
going on because she tried to block me
seeing him during the covered locked
hounds
um
uh again I didn't have a car
she said well you can have Ernie
for these times but you have to I'm only
gonna go halfway
which was a place called cirencester
which you can't get something that
you've got a car
or bus which takes an hour
um
so
she was then starting to try and over
time if you look at it it was every over
the over that first well two years to
three years it was very small
incremental changes that would be enough
to get away with at the time but then
add up to quite big changes
um which is gaslighting
um
does your son know any of this is going
on
I've spoke to him about it
I think he's aware especially more now
um
I'll try to keep him out of it it's
difficult
especially when you catch you would come
to the door and then start shouting at
me at the door
um John kovich once came to my house wow
she broke into the house once as well
she broke into your house
for what okay to get uh to get her stuff
which she had she had six weeks to get
her stuff and she was coming in outside
the house and eventually I was realizing
that other things were going so I
thought okay I need to change the locks
of the house now because it's too much
for my own sanity right it's time she
broke into the house
then were you able to file a police
report I filed a police report
because she was on the mortgage
she didn't do anything about it and
that's like good evidence that it was
her father doing it which I believe it
was because I couldn't evidence that
they couldn't do anything about it
although the police to be fair
wanted anything like they wanted to
arrest her they didn't have enough to
arrest her at that point
so the police were on your side oh yeah
about three or four times where the
police have been involved and every time
they're on my side
and was there any like you said you had
one fight in seven years
like how did you not notice that like
there's this she sounds insane based on
what you're saying like this sounds all
crazy was there like warning signs when
you guys were dating when you not when
we were dating no no
um so if I look back she was a childish
she was a person who would just go into
a flood of Tears for no reason so you
could if you wanted to have a talk a
serious talk about something
all of a sudden she'd been full of tears
and then you'd like our women because
um the one argument like the pushback
that I always get is like why don't you
just tell them to pick the right girl
um so that's a hard thing because you
don't know someone on the day we met
almost like a couple weeks after being
married she changed
how old was she when you guys got
married
so she was 29 and I was well I just
don't uh I turned 30 and how long after
how long did you date before that
we were together for three years prior
to that and we were living together for
about wow
and you had no there's no inkling before
you got married
and then once you got married I've heard
this you're not the only guy that said
that um but on the outside looking in
it's like
not one inkling in three years how do
you look back it's a different perspect
of retrospective right
um in hindsight hindsight's a great
thing right yeah when you look back you
go
damn like what warning signs were there
just because there's going to be guys
watching Family
so her family was very toxic her father
is pathological narcissist okay proper
game player
and he would purposely because I was the
uneducated person
the person you wanted to pick on
um we'd be in a lounge
and
my ex-wife would usually be calling the
kitchen by his mother by her mother
and I've been in around with one of my
younger sisters one of the the sisters
husbands and this conversation was like
almost going around this table like a
whirlwind and eventually it would be
stopping at me and it will turn on me
out of humiliation did you make me
um
when my son was born I was basically
being told that I was going to be a
useless father
she told you that or he did they were
basically telling me that they were
telling me
um all indirectly
what do you mean indirectly so by
certain comments so it would be
um
for example
oh you're gonna be there for the birth
are you oh okay
like no excitement I'm there to support
her
um tell you what rather you know at the
birth you you do what you got to do and
then just go straight back to work we
got we got it from here
and what you said a couple weeks after
you guys got married something changed
it's like what what change could you put
your finger on it I would change that
all of a sudden it was like she had me
I was doing something online my my my
business stuff
and all of a sudden she came in I said I
could just call it shop first of all so
what you're doing my taxes and whatever
else
on why are you doing that for
because I need to do it and bear in mind
her parents the other week or a couple
weeks before going we're talking about
tax all the time taxes tax that taxes
saying to me almost like you don't know
you have to pay your taxes yet do you
are you going to be paying your taxes
like I was never gonna be good enough
um
and then I said Indiana said look please
just leave me alone let me get on with
it you know
ing that he was her father
in the back
and then she said
um so why can't I get involved it's my
business so just let me get on with it
well actually the half of mine and
walked out the room
she said that
it's half of mine
I mean I literally at that point was
like whoa
right that's a cussing remark yeah
um
on the run-up to a wedding
her family didn't want me involved in
the wedding planning I was told just
turn up on the day in the suit they told
me to wear
was not an involvement in it at all and
it was just getting do you want to be
involved yeah which is my part of my day
so some some guys don't I don't know if
I didn't phone off I did but you so you
were actively trying to be involved and
they kept telling you just show up
that's it yeah
so all this little stuff in hindsight
made sense but none of it was like big
enough to really set off your alarm
Bells no no I would think or the average
guys because
um the reason I'm asking is there's just
guys that watch this and
like how how could they avoid these type
of women is there any way to tell
I've been asked this question quite a
few times by by guys
um sometimes you don't know what a lot
until when it's too late but also
there's a period of time
well I would say little things were
going on little niggles and I just put
it hard on my back don't worry about it
just you know grinning carry on going
and carry on it's okay I
um uh I can deal with this and there's
also an element of failure I think for
me really if I look back and go
I can't ever say I I and I make this
point I will not say I regret the
marriage because my son came out of the
marriage to regret the marriage would
regret my child and that would never
ever happen okay make that pretty clear
[Music]
um
but looking back I was making a lot of
I was being over fair with things
almost sounds like for a good life you
know always going oh I've got to be
wrong for this oh you know I need to see
it from her perspective and you know we
always have to in a relationship don't
get me wrong then looking back I did it
that many times where she didn't really
try to see your person back there and I
think if you look back as well when
before we even got engaged
um because her family was starting to
put pressure on me to get engaged as
well
um again there's another
early pressure needs to get engaged
there should be no pressure on anybody
yet engaged
it should be when they're happy to do it
um and then all of a sudden it was if
there was anything financial and we both
had to pay something always
did things 50 50.
if it was for example was 20 pence over
my side that's fine if it was 20 over on
other side because sometimes things just
work out however it works out you know
explains me why I'm paying more money
well there's nothing the other right I
paid 100 pounds more last month for
example right you know that was okay so
it's like all of a sudden that sudden
unfairness was okay if it was on her
side
um sorry I'm Fair sorry
the unfairness was okay if it was unfair
for me financially but not foreign
[Music]
but you wouldn't say there's any like if
people met her at 25 or I think you met
her 26 you said you got engaged yeah
like they would never
like there wouldn't be anything that's
different about her in a room or like
you know um because I think
15 of women of marriages end like this
according to some of the research I'm
looking at not men getting ruined but
it's higher but um like women spitefully
ruining men if that makes sense oh right
yeah um according like there's some
there's obviously going to be debate
about the numbers but half of only half
of marriages end in divorce so it's like
one out of every three divorces ends
like this
um where the woman is actively like
trying to ruin and destroy the man and
that's
it's a higher number than that but they
they give a little Grace because maybe
there are some you know that where the
guy is bad you know they have to yeah
yeah absolutely yeah so so
um like so out of every 10 women one to
two might do it so like what was
anything different about her
outside of you said the family was tots
toxic and she had a crazy father but I'm
just curious if a guy meets a 25 or 26
year old
awesome I would say
the initial look for the love bombing
stage
they were getting messages
loads of messages all the time okay are
you getting on you know and it's kind of
um
that stage is look out for that it's a
nice time
you know if you think you're loved and
then things suddenly start going
like nitpicks
you know
um
so for me for example
really even look right back
probably personality wise we weren't
we weren't weren't the same
um
uh our values were clearly very very
different
um I like to be tidy she like to be
messy that's fine some people either way
you know
um
uh
I was you know she moved into me with me
in Swindon from Bournemouth
into all went back flats or something
like we have to be tidy because I was
literally uh you trip over everything
you know it's a point where there's a
little bit of mess but you've got to be
mindful of stuff right you know
um and
there was just no I suppose we didn't
believe in the same thing
and I tend I I bit a lot of it and I
think that then becomes uh
not just that many different things it
becomes a habit to
um
to bottle things bottle things that
trigger you press a button if you like a
bit of anxiety right
um and here's the things that her family
I didn't recognize her family
well
to be fair at the beginning her mother
wasn't exactly great towards me
um because I was a a guy who
did everything from Grassroots I wasn't
educated
um and kind of looked at down at her
nose at me
ironic her father was well I did exact
same thing as Graham so he kind of liked
and respected me for it as I thought her
sisters were like he hasn't got a degree
and that wasn't that was enough
even when self-employed uh
brother-in-law
in my
Garden said sorry am I
hmm so have I gone too far no
um would say to me can anybody open a
business you don't need any
qualifications anything like that but
yeah anybody can open a business
even you
so
you know there's triggers there you go
actually there was lots of stuff there
going on
that I didn't see
none of this sounds like anything crazy
though none of the like none of this
sounds like anything that was that
extraordinary if you look at it
individually right like none of these
and then you concatenate it all yeah but
that's what I mean because a lot of the
big criticism
um because I don't I don't put this
I believe in the institution of marriage
but I just think the way it's set up
today is insane and I don't know how in
good faith I could recommend a guy does
it with like knowing what I before I
knew that but a lot of the criticism
like from more of the like I'm
conservative so a lot of like the
conservatives in my space will say well
why don't you just pick the right girl
but I mean minus the toxic family none
of this is that
crazy you know like a couple snide
comments here and there nitpicks like
that sounds like normal relationship I
mean not not the best relationship but
like that sounds like normal stuff that
can happen in a relationship yeah yeah
so yeah and here's the thing if you
haven't been in relationship before
how would you know what's normal and
what's healthy what's your first
relationship so it was my first
relationship but she was well yeah she
was my first proper girlfriend okay
um so do you feel like she and I'm
guessing she had more relationships
before you yet I've also found out the
week after we got married or got got
back off honeymoon she had a boyfriend
she was living in Bournemouth right she
moved to Swindon and it turned out that
boyfriend was also living in Swindon but
she didn't tell me
oh so you think she was seeing him too
no no I don't think she was seeing him
she would tell me about his ex her
ex-boyfriend
and if I look back and what she would
say oh
um uh apparently he abused her as well
by talking down to her or not treating
her nicely this and that and the other
and the things she was putting against
me they're like oh she kind of makes
sense like this is like repeated a
repeating pattern so that's a similar
and it turned out she said to me oh yeah
I
so she said to me she didn't know
anybody in Swindon that's when she came
to Swindon okay so I made sure she in
great integrate my family and my friends
and got her Sat Nav uh
saw what you call Sat Nav in America uh
GPS oh okay okay navigation
um so she could get around Swindon
because you know when I'm not with her
if she needs to get certain places
um
uh
I just said she didn't know anybody in
Swindon and never really came to Swindon
Park to see her sister because her
sister happens to live in Swindon to be
fair that was the only people she knew
in Swindon and then a week or two after
coming back from honeymoon
oh yeah that my ex-boyfriend I told you
about he used to live there
so I used to come swimming a lot
so oh so she lied to you about that do
you think this was her plan from the
beginning
what to do what she did to me yeah
no no I don't believe it was or at least
not what I saw
do I look back and think
was this always going to happen I do
think now yes but I think a lot of it
was more subconscious
about to actually are consciously doing
it
um
uh I don't think there was a
particularly a plan
but I just think
there's a lot of subconscious things
going on
why did you choose to fight for your son
because I love him with all my heart
did you ever think about not
because of all the trouble you had to go
through
there's a point where
I didn't see him for four months
and I had to turn my heart to a swinging
brick because that's the only way I
could get on every day
[Music]
um
because it's a little pressure
I was like why am I doing but it's just
worth it
it's just that it's just that self-doubt
not that he's not worth it he's
absolutely worth it
I'd go bankrupt five times if I had to
to keep him I do I spend five times the
amount of money if I had to
but it's that moment of where you where
you where you where I was in this
situation I'm saying you as a third
person sorry if I say you
um
and you realize how much is stacked
against you
third person attacked against me
um
I was like can I do this
can I do this
and
then just looking at photos it was no he
deserves this
he deserves this and I always wanted I
always wanted to be a committed father
anyway
um there's a point and I spoke so when I
was in the contact centers I spoke to a
lot of fathers
but I was no father spoke to each other
when you first went in because they
thought everybody was guilty apart from
them
because you don't know who's going who's
not if he's not saying you must be
guilty of something you know and I
actually spoke to everybody in their the
same story was going around
um the same story of the mother or not
yeah
well if I was in that situation I don't
know if I would fight to be honest
it's it's actually very admirable that
you did I I used to really
um think really low of dads that didn't
like take the mom to court and fight for
their kids but you know the more I learn
how at the drop of a hat they can take
you to court again and claim abuse again
I don't know if I would honestly if I
was in your shoes
uh
we'll have to go back to cool I would go
back to school
you know it don't go wrong it would be a
difficult decision
but my son is worth more than that
and for me
he deserves better than that
um
I should have had 50 50.
I think explained it didn't happen but I
I
couldn't have him not in my life
why don't you think the courts value
fathers
why do fathers only get primary custody
ten percent of the time
I think a lot of it goes back to the
female activism I agree with equality
and I agree with feminism I've got an
issue with that but I think there's a
toxic side of it and
um when Margaret Thatcher was in
um
uh in in government
that's when a lot of this stuff was
being put in place the mother was
primary
because it was believed that the mother
could be the only one who provides the
best
parenting
got it so you think that brainwashing
of constantly saying that the kid needs
to be that's a common phrase I think the
kid that needs his mother but I don't
know there's never a comment of the the
kidneys I felt yeah I've never before I
got into I mean now I've heard that
because I'm in this specific space but
like how many people even know this
exists like I don't think it's the
majority
so you think it's the brainwashing then
most of the judges
um grew up or in that media grew up in
the media then what goes on in the
government
did you just really have to abide by
set rules
explain that a little more so
um
in the Judiciary mean the judges okay
all the laws and
um
parenting laws and things that we call
them laws or rules
it's all first of all abide um created
by the local government the the
governments
um
to determine bias to determine not know
what they call bias in the computer
system so
um
so I'm trying to explain it I've got it
in my head but I'm not quite explaining
it right
um
so they've got those so
one of the key things I told you about
the
um
uh the pillars and the spectrum of D.A
that's one of the biggest
pushes
oh so say in my scenario in my case
the mother escaped with the child and
just went away so much he did me
um she's now because I he's not in my
care primary
if I went with my son I have a class of
primary but technically I could still
lose him
well Technic say that again I could
technically even though I say could I
write okay I've got to leave here now
this is not a good bun I gotta take my
son in the same scenario a father does
it it's taken Shadow over have dare the
father do that
the father can't flee and mother can
flee your father can't if the father
flees he's looked down upon where if the
mother flees she's not but she's just
and he's looked at as like there had to
be a reason that she fled yeah
and
the issue is that when they get to court
she can claim abuse with this point
system yep and woman's Idols he knows
the system called it implemented so you
also mentioned that women's Aid 80
percent of cases I think you said this
before the interview but you said 80
percent of cases at Women's Aid are
fraudulent
um could you explain that so they know
their false allegation
so they
um
so they know
that the people who are going to them
asking for help that 80 of them
is false allegation they know that it's
not actually true
now when I went to court
they she my wife my ex-wife had what's
called a McKenzie friend and it was a
lady from women's Aid in the courtroom
and she was just passing notes
she first tried to refuse to tell the
court her name
until the judge ordered her to do it and
even then on two attempts said just her
first name
the court then said we now know you
because obviously what they've done in
the first hearing she'd done the first
hearing and what she this lady was doing
was passing notes
um every time I would say something in
court she would pass a note that would
suddenly go
that's where the um
in the second hearing for
demanding Behavior came about
that's the best oh so you said that you
asked for toys or something so my ex
brought forward there's demanding
Behavior
and that goes under the abuse
wow so she oh I didn't realize that was
a device she was given from women's age
wow so I didn't realize that demanding
Behavior like I didn't realize that was
under abuse so because you asked for son
you you so you asked for toys for your
son and she came in and said this is
demanding behavior and abuse correct
because the woman from women's Aid was
writing this down
and there's no way in how these women
are stupid like they know that's not
abusive but because they get more money
I'm guessing it's just about silver
bullets they get more money based on
winning in court
and when the stats go we've got more
people are being domestically abused
therefore we need more funds from the
government
oh so they like they almost inflate the
the numbers
so I I one guy told me that in 2013 when
they switched the law for abuse where
you get free counsel that abuse
allegations went up over 200 percent
yes so if you get say women's Aid to say
so so basically you go to court and you
don't have a you don't have a lawyer or
anything because you're broke because
she's drained you at this point and it's
usually I I found six months to a year
roughly that tell you and usually the
dads haven't seen their sons in six so
they're already
high stress I'd imagine they're already
really frustrated some of them lose
their jobs in this time because if you
take your kid like I wouldn't be
mentally stable if someone took my child
from me so
um
then you go to court and they're kind of
waiting for you to say any like one they
already have a list of everything you've
done wrong in the past couple of years
or they could construe is wrong to call
it abuse so they can file it under the
abuse court system so that's like
Financial abuse coercive control and
emotional abuse and the the last one you
just said which is that demanding
demanding behavior I'm gonna write that
over here and I think he's part of the
coercive coercive control is oh I just
ran out but I don't demanding now it's
back demanding Behavior so then
and they're also these women are waiting
on everything you say in court so if you
one if you act agitated then they say
see he did abuse me if so and if you say
anything wrong then the women's Aid are
just writing things down and hanging
Post-it notes yeah and handing it and
oftentimes I think women's Aid will give
you counsel too so that she might have a
lawyer from women's aid but the lawyers
I've also heard that even if you get a
lawyer they might not have your best
interests at heart because they
um their number one customer is women's
Aid so they can't win too many cases
otherwise women's why would women say
give you the customers right yep yeah
yep so but so it's it's kind of a money
train right and what you have is a
solicitor who that so fitting with me
they're doing the father yeah
but also they're also dealing with a
mother somewhere else as well so that's
giving me advice as a father
to go okay you need to angle it this way
and angle it that way and then they're
going to a mother who is being toxic
okay to get the best out of out of him
you need to do this and that and the
other
and then she's saying to me
um uh well we'll have to wait and see
what they say and then we'll decide what
we're going to do but it's usually it's
all
so I once spent in three months with
with a solicitor
1000 pounds okay
and I had nothing all I did was hand
over statements and they picked holes in
the statements and that's what they
already did for a thousand pounds
they picked holes in your statements
okay so they didn't help you at all and
at that point you're you're struggling
so it's kind of like to get to a lawyer
that could help you you probably have to
go through good like we're
doing some legal stuff here and what we
have to go through bad lawyers good like
because you kind of have to spend money
but it's not like you have money to
spend but her on the other hand she gets
it all for free
yep so she can go through lawyers find
the best lawyer get the best counsel
all for a year wow well I have to pay
for it yeah and then there's also it
doesn't seem like there's any
consequence for alienating the father
like there's no jail time there's no
number two well some people have there
are some people who have been uh taken
to prison for a very extreme PA
apparently animation that's very very
rare So what are ways to mitigate risk
were there any was there anything you
could have done to mitigate the risk if
I had my time again
and I believe this should actually in
this day and age
I believe it should be mandatory for any
marriage going forward
to be even the birth of your or before
the birth of your first child or the
point your first marriage is you have to
sign a prenuptial agreement and it has
to be signed by a judge
so when you get married you have to get
a well in America you have to get a
license get a similar sort of marriage
license in the UK okay at that point
that's when a prenuptial agreement needs
to be put into place
yeah
um uh uh at the birth of the first well
near the birth of the first child at a
point where you go with birth
certificate
to register their name that's when it
also should be done and I'll be there to
be a template where everything is 50 50.
let's both agreed to the point where
you're most happiest
um
the appointment really
you're hoping No One's Gonna
argue against it oh yeah of course we
can do fish why wouldn't we do that
because I had conversations with my
ex-wife
seeing parents with their kids breaking
them up and saw it you know seeing what
they were doing I'd never do that in my
career you know I was saying I would
never do that with
Ernie and she was like oh I wouldn't do
that either I'd make sure that wow so
she told you I would never do that I
can't believe and so many friends have
said that as well
and I said but what happens if you do
break up
okay oh I think we just get on with it
and I said
that's what I thought you know I don't
mean to be a sticker
and I've always said to so many people
um most loveliest couples will go have
you got a prenupted agreement in place
and it's not so much just because to
prevent someone being nasty it just
makes the whole process easier there is
no argument
so I believe is part of a marriage
license there should be a prenuptial
agreement a template one you know the
government goes right unless you
actually know because not everybody is
legal minded so in the first instance it
should be a basic template and and also
determines
uh parental forget you know if this
first child and that would go here's the
first child prenuptial agreement any
future children on top of that
regardless marriage or not at the point
of marriage
prenatal agreement of all assets and
children
and you know kind of 50 50 you basically
put in there standard 50 50. so 50 50
split prenup is there anything else
yeah Financial assets so what a
prenuptial agreement will be Financial
assets anyway okay as well as children
yeah
um and
Financial assets children
and your businesses I guess okay which
will be part of financial but
um
pensions substantial she took 40 30 of
my pensions including your pensions even
the pensions I accumulate before we met
uh for seven years together she took
thirty percent here that's crazy got
robbed yeah
um
what about you guys's savings would you
take those
um wow originally here's the thing I had
a letter for merciles to saying we're
going to Green queer clean break we're
not going to touch a pension it's not
going to cut touch your savings but
we'll do some of the house and then she
wouldn't have done 100 of all profits in
the house nothing Fair down the line
um when it got to actually to court they
totally denied where that had that
conversation
then with my pensions obviously by that
point I was bankrupt anyway I had no
money
for much because she already took
exactly everything
um they actually even though I was
already bankrupt they were saying to the
judge he's threatening to go bankrupt
okay I'm already bankrupt I've already
been declared
um
yeah
were you able to see your son when you
you mentioned you were homeless for a
period of time
um I had to see uh
so yes so that was last year
because I was in a hostel obviously
even if I could see him take my son now
I never would have done you know I'm
never in a million years would I ever
done
um so I would take my son to hotels
when it was cheap enough for me to do so
when it became summer obviously when
things Skyrocket for hotel prices I had
camping equipment
and I took him camping all summer
because that's the only way I could see
him it wasn't just about holidays it was
the only way I could see him
so I'd be going away from a Friday to a
Sunday or it was a bank holiday weekend
Friday to the Monday
just so I could see him
um so going to proper camping sites you
know family orientated camping sites
um once we camped as long as we can for
was eight days and then it was a couple
of six and seven it was a six and a
seven and a few like four or five day
ones are you still in court now no no
you're done
and it's settled basically you see him
every two weeks every two weeks
um
uh and you think after all this time
everything should be moved on but every
six to eight weeks she tries to get me
involved in an argument
of some sort so she can
play
arguments of behavior
so every six to eight weeks how does she
do that she calls you so for example
um I had my son's sports day
and she said to me please don't sit near
me
um
uh please don't sit near me
um because I'm scared of you
and I said don't be so stupid I'm not
gonna get involved in this my son was
next to his mother you know his mother I
am not going to ignore my son for you
um another one was I was going to a
birthday party with one of my sons
and one of her friends
um like an informant if you like was
that was there and all of a sudden I had
this message from my ex going oh don't
worry about bringing them back home
um my friend is going to bring him home
I said I don't know your friend so I'm
gonna do it I'm his father
now I want you to bring her home I heard
her to bring him home so no I'm not
going to do it I'm going to take my son
home
to you it was it wasn't like 10 minutes
it was like 10 20 minute Journey from he
was closer to her house and mine
and that then caused an argument I was
being argumentative
um she was scared of me at the front
door didn't want me at her front door
um when I went to this kid's party this
friend of hers had mixed everything up
already that I was being argumentative
that I didn't want her and I didn't
trust her friend how dare I'd not trust
her and does she try to take you to
court again after this or what I don't
think she'll ever take me to court I'd
have to take her to court okay
um so there was a time when I said about
um when I sold my car
she said to me she gave me five days to
agree
to her changes
um if I don't agree to it I can't see
any
and then over five days I'd name out of
date two more days to go yeah three more
days ago two more speeds to go if you
don't agree to it then we're just going
to accept going to understand if you
need to agree to this there was no
option to reject if you don't agree to
it
then you know you're not going to see
him
and she was
if I didn't agree to it I would she said
you'll have to go back to court if you
don't want me to do make these changes
wow
this is crazy I can't believe this is
legal actually
um
but yeah it looks like I love my son and
I will do anything I've got to do for
him
I've now got a flat now which is lucky
through Housing Association because
obviously in a hostel I couldn't work
and whatever right do you have a new job
not at the moment no so I've had to
during that time my health went so far
down yeah I can imagine yeah
um I realized at the beginning of
January I had to get my health back to
scratch I was in the hostel so I
couldn't go anywhere anyway I wasn't
allowed to work Believe It or Not these
systems are you weren't allowed to work
no so if you're in a hostel right
believe it or not they say you need you
know we're going to help you get out of
this situation but they won't let you
work out of the situation
oh wow
so how would you get out if you can't
work I have to wait to get a house
through a Housing Association okay which
can take up to two and a half years
wow I I was out in 11 months so they're
almost like making you they're making it
almost impossible make it look easy yeah
but it's impossible yeah without their
help right could you imagine these
housings like why aren't you allowed to
work that doesn't make any sense because
if you're working you're claiming you're
then paying employment tax right and
that therefore means if you're earning I
mean you should be able to pay pay
um rent
because obviously if you did work
I would if I'd worked I'd been given two
weeks notice so what time have I got to
a earn a deposit for a place and get my
first video
and a deposit and the first month's rent
before I even go anywhere and you're not
gonna do that in two weeks
so then you're out on the street again
wait I don't get that so if you if you
get a job that like they say you can't
get a job if you do we'll give you two
weeks notice oh so they kick you out of
the hostel if you get a job that's
correct yeah
I thought hostels are just like anyone
can pay for them now
um this one was paid by my local Council
oh okay
although you can but it would be like
300 pounds a week oh and then how would
you do that without a job
right because then if that happened I'd
have to pay that two weeks back for them
so it'll be 600 pounds six to even
sometimes even a thousand pounds in debt
did you ever feel like um
do you feel like your wife would have
your ex-wife would have acted
differently had you had made more money
no no you think she would already
earning good money what are you earning
about three 350 pounds a day oh wow
oh that's gross that's net yeah right
that is gross as well yeah but um so no
um you think she would have done the
same thing regardless yeah yeah and she
actually on the day I I was leaving the
house she came in
so I had to put my stuff into storage
and in the end she had to pay for my
storage so I had no money
I just my back had I raced to try and
get everything done
um I had to call to my car and get and
call into a e
which is the accent room
um because I couldn't walk I done I did
my backing
and I was accused of
um delaying things and making lies up
making excuses up one point I had heart
palpitations I was in there again I was
having ECGs I had two ECGs and gone on
some blood tests
and I was still making it up
um so she had to put everything in
storage and there had to be a removal
company coming in and she purposely
because she knew I might have to go
there was a particular hostel in the in
the Town Center run by the Salvation
Army
because that's where I thought I'd have
to go
um
and she knew I would have to check in
because I said
I need that removal van
not till midday 12 o'clock because I
need to check into the hostel first and
then come back so she personally made it
at exactly half past nine
so you couldn't make it
do you have any resentment over this
whole thing
it's hard not to I think really yeah
um as far as I'm concerned I think
things should be moving on now and I
don't believe she's actually been on
this wave trying to be the victim and I
had to say to a judge at one point for
the divorce proceedings
so we've got the child proceedings and
the divorce kind of two there are two
separate things I'd say to him you
cannot let us carry on soon this divorce
is going to last last longer than the
marriage
we were married three years and 11
months before she said before she left
wow so imagine four and a half years
including the son of the house right the
divorced low we were divorced before
then technically it was still
financially tied until a house goes so
really it's like being married
um I said it's gonna be it's gonna you
know I shouldn't you know this is I'm
being tortured here
would you ever get married again
I've been asked this question quite a
few times
there was a time I'll flat right say no
I think sometimes I'll still say no
if I was pushed to ask the question I
would but with a cast iron prenupt
agreement signed by a judge
because any prenup certainly in the UK
that's not signed by a judge is only a
piece of paper
has to be signed by a judge and it
doesn't cost a lot of money to do it
well thank you so much for coming I
really appreciate it
um I'm really sorry this happened to you
this is actually insane
um but thank you so many questions I
haven't answered perhaps now I think um
is there anything that we missed that
you wanted to talk about
um no no I don't think so
um I felt as though a couple of times
perhaps I might um I might have gone off
course a little bit or or perhaps I
might not answer the question properly
or no I think I I understood
um no I think you're you're okay this is
a good interview I think we got like two
hours worth of content oh really oh wow
gosh yeah how long was it geez that's
like two hours oh wow oh gosh okay it's
quite intense
um yeah but thank you so much for coming
in um do you have any I don't know if
some guys have like channels or do you
have any social media you want to plug
you guys have questions
um email if guys have questions anything
you want to plug for people to contact
you
um
so the best place I would say is there's
two
um
for help in the UK
there is a fast for justice
organization in the US as well that's
linked to the files of the Justice page
in the UK anything any legal help you
need use them straight away if there's
any issues with kids
they are your first bet they're far
cheaper than a solicitor I'd probably
have been more 50 60 000 pounds in costs
had I went to a solicitor
um
in terms of
there's a lot of groups out there
and kind of
um
lots of group Pages for alienated
parents so print alienation UK
um support group that's a good support
to go to I'm part of the PA UK
um
uh
campaign group
um
I'm not sure what how Pi would be
personally for these people
um
so I don't know whether I should be
doing that or not I don't know because I
don't know what worth it would be for
well I mean even with this um
guys will email me and ask her advice I
usually just point them on to someone
else so it's up to you some some guys
want
I don't know some some guys want their
stuff out there some don't so it's up to
you I I think I'm okay with that I think
that's okay I'm not being married I was
like well I don't know what you know
speak to this person and that's what
I'll be doing you know so I might as
well say go straight to those people
um
uh yeah there's a lot of Sports Group
out there uh so two groups in the UK
files need fathers
um hold on no families need fathers is a
good group
um and good organization to help with
any form of
children's issues and uh uh files for
justice is a good group for the UK
um if there is I do know there's an F
for J in the US and there's also one in
Australia as well
that are linked obviously the separate
organizations but they're linked
altogether
um
there are a lot of advice voice pages
be careful because it's very easy to get
so ingrained in them
that actually has quite
an emotional pressure on your chest
so take it with
be mindful when using those groups
because a lot of repetition happens
but it's a good thing to acknowledge
that other people are going through this
as well so you can kind of look back on
yourself and go
I'm not the only one
and it actually allowed me certainly
through PA UK
to realize what I needed
the selfish needs that things are needed
like my health believe it or not weird
to say health is a selfish thing but
where I realized okay I now need to
construct my mental health and physical
health
um
focus on those two things first
um because if you don't
it will make you very very unwell and
there's been many fathers who have
committed suicide
I've been there three times
um
in suicidal State please do not do it
um your kids need you
um obviously I don't know the state of
the legal system too much in the US I
should imagine
a lot of money is spent on them as well
so I'd advise well I can't say I advise
but I'd recommend seeking out
people like files for justice who can
actually help you
um
and actually give you proper advice and
actually how to properly stretch
yourself ready for court
um
so yeah look out for the support groups
but don't get too ingrained in it
because it can bring you down a little
bit and they kind of have to come up and
come up for air because remember you
still will live yourself thank you so
much for coming
um guys make sure you like the video on
your way out subscribe to the channel
um and let me know who I should
interview next if there's anyone in that
has to do with the court system an
illegal attorney I should interview let
me know in the comments subscribe to the
channel and I'll talk to you next time